most of the time whale sharks are just
drifters kind of gently slowly moving
along and they tend to circle you
they're very curious animals so you get
to know these individuals because
they're where they're waiting for the
fish and you're there waiting for the
fish so they kind of just check each
other out so they're just get these long
shots what he'll just continue our
soldiers continue to circle around and
kind of dipper fins every now and then
sort of acknowledge your presence but
they know they know you're there and
they know they don't they're not
threatened by you but generally they
stick around and when they want to get
away from you it's boom I mean they can
swim insanely fast much faster than we
can so they let you hang out with them
when they want to and then when you're
in the spawn you tend to find yourself
trying to get the looking straight down
the mouth shot which is such a great
shot and you're kind of in their way cuz
while they're slow they are moving so
they kind of like come on dude get out
of my way I'm trying to eat I waited all
year for this and you know so you're
sitting there trying to film and you
just know god I hate these guys and then
on occasion you run into the very
curious whale shark um there was one
occasion when we were it was midday
nothing was really happening we found
this fairly big 15 20 foot young male
who was very very interested in dan and
I and wouldn't leave and kept coming up
and kind of try and nibble at our
stomachs he was like he was playing it
was like he wanted to kind of hang out
that's the way you need to do that was
kind of bump us and for me 20-30 minutes
this this whale shark would just come up
to Dan and kind of just nudge him and
then you come up to me and kind of nudge
him and whirling worth the very surface
of the water and it was just it was
really insane being that close and
having that intimate moment with
something that big and he didn't want to
hurt us at all he was just a big gentle
curious young male whale shark it was a
it was a lot of fun and on the whole we
don't touch them and we don't
inhibit their movements in any way so
you know other than are just mere
presence which probably drives them a
little nuts but and then they feed and
let them go on their way and they get
famous so it's cool